[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo meine lieben es gibt wieder ein
ein Teig dreip Plätzchen Rezept von mir
es gab in den vergangenen Jahren immer
mal wieder ein Teig viele Plätzchen
Rezepte oder auch 1 Kilogramm Mehl 250
Plätzchen also ich habe dieses Game
komplett durchgespielt aber diesmal habe
ich mir wieder drei geniale Rezepte vor
euch überlegt bzw alle drei aus nur ein
schnellen basisteig und ich würde mal
sagen wir legen direkt los wir starten
mit unserem basic Teig wie immer ganz
ganz einfacher Teig ich benutze jetzt
hier die Küchenmaschine und nehme jetzt
zimmerwarme Butter das ist jetzt ein
bisschen untypisch weil normalerweise
bei Keksteig Butter immer so richtig
kalt sein muss aber das ist mein Trick
17 die wird jetzt nämlich schön cremig
also so dicklig geschlagen das macht die
Kekse später richtig zart da kommt jetzt
einmal Zucker mit dazu dann Salz Salz
unterstreicht und heb noch mal den süßen
Geschmack und dann das ganze jetzt mit
der Maschine braucht es echt nur so 2
Minuten wenn ihr ein handröhgerät habt
gerne 45 Minuten lang schlagen und dann
geht's weiter mit den
[Musik]
Eiern die Eier habe ich jetzt auch kurz
mit eingerührt es ist immer besser wenn
bei diesem Rezept jetzt die Eier auch
auf Zimmertemperatur sind wenn nicht
dann ist es auch nicht so schim dann
sieht es nur für einen Moment grisselig
aus und ja du hast ein bisschen
erschrcken eine Frage ich stand gerade
hier Leute ich stand gerade hier rechts
weil ich raus gezeigt habe dann fragst
du gerade hinter den kuliss sieht man
ihn und Jasmin sagt zu nee und du sagst
okay gut willst du mich verstecken bin
ich so hlich nein Quatsch ich sag doch
sogar sei dabei im Video natürlich wei
komm mir rein gerne doch mil kommt jetzt
rein ohne es zu sieben das Rezept ist so
einfach sicher ich verkackt ja
nein ja h noch welche extra Wünsche ja
man muss alles alles reintun ja sehr
schön teigscher jetzt ne auch dur da ist
doch nichts mehr drin doch ja die 2 g
hier h gewaschen klar meine Hände sind
immer gewaschen vom Dreh nicht und jetzt
rümen wir das nur ganz kurz ein erstmal
denkt i das verbindet sich nie weil da
so viel Mehl drin ist und dann
irgendwann nach ein paar Sekunden ist
eine richtig schöne Keksmasse aber bitte
nicht die hohe Stufe sonst haben wir
bitte nicht ne Bock drauf nein bitte
nicht
nein das das reicht dasufe ein Nein das
ist gut ja ja ist gut mehr nicht nein
auch nicht zwei jetzt einfach geschehen
lassen nein nicht Z ist passiert einfach
passieren lassen wie so ein kleines Kind
D ein Scheiße bauen
[Musik]
will der Teig ist fertig ihr merkt auch
daran dass der fertig ist dass der ist
nur so ganz leicht klebrig aber er klebt
jetzt nicht an euren Händen also ihr
seht EU eure Handabdrücke im Teig quasi
so und jetzt knete ich das aber noch mal
ein paar Sekunden hier auf meiner
Silikonmatte ihr könnt auch ein bisschen
Mehl gerne dazu geben wenn ihr das
Gefühl habt da fehlt noch ein bisschen
was an Mehl und da wir jetzt aus einem
Teig drei Kekse machen teile ich den
jetzt auch durch drei und dann wird der
als werden die Teige dann schon einzeln
quasi im jeweiligen Geschmack
aromatisiert ich mach das jetzt echt P
mal Daumen ich finde gerade beim Kekse
backen muss halt einfach nicht so
perfekt
zugehen ist schon Zahl wie viel ist den
pchus vi dann geht weiter ja W jetzt
noch mal nach der 144 zu wissen den
ersten Teig verarbeiten wir jetzt zu
haselnusseksen und da gebe ich jetzt
einfach gemahlene Haselnusskerne direkt
hiermit rein und arbeitet das ein wenn
ihr merkt das ist irgendwie ein bisschen
trocken könnt ihr noch ein Schluck Milch
dazu geben aber es sollte eigentlich
kein Problem sein weil die Butter und
die Eier die enthalten jetzt eigentlich
genug Feuchtigkeit so und danach einfach
in Frischhaltefolie wickeln und dann
kommt es in den Kühlschrank so für Teig
Nummer 2 habe ich einfach Kakao mit
reingegeben da könnt ihr jetzt entweder
Backkakao nehmen oder trink Kakao ich
habe diesen trinkkakao nie da um ehrlich
zu sein deshalb ist es jetzt bei mir
Backkakao aber es funktioniert
tatsächlich beides so und jetzt kommt
der dritte Teig und da wir daraus
Vanille walnussplätzchen machen kommt
hier einfach Vanilleextrakt mit rein
natürlich hättet ihr auch in den
gesamten Grundteig Vanille mit reingeben
können aber der Geschmack wird ja auch
noch mal so ein bisschen übertönt gleich
weil teilweise ja noch mit Schokolade
überzogen wird etc und hier gebe ich
jetzt die volle Dröhnung Vanille mit
rein damit man bei jedem Bissen so
richtig intensiv Vanille Geschmack hat
so und da könnt ihr dadurch dass es
Extrakt ja es ist sehr dickfüssig da
könnt ihr jetzt noch ein bisschen Mehl
einfach noch mit dazu geben beim Kneten
und dann werden alle drei Teige in
Frischhaltefolie gewickelt und dann
müsst ihr sie 60 Minuten lang in den
Kühlschrank stellen übrigens wenn ihr
jetzt gar keine Zeit habt dann gehen
auch 30 Minuten im Gefrierfach ansonsten
wie gesagt 60 Minuten im Kühlschrank los
geht's jetzt mit dem haselnussteig
daraus werden jetzt Haselnuss kipfall
das Gute ist jetzt während der Kühlzeit
hat sich der Zucker schön in den Teig
verarbeitet und ich knete das jetzt mit
den Händen nur noch ganz kurz
geschmeidig und dann rolle ich so ein
Strang aus weil dann kann man sich da
richtig schön die ganzen kipfall einmal
zurecht schneiden und
[Musik]
Formen
mein Strang ist jetzt 2 cm dick nur
damit ihr da so eine Vorstellung von
habt wenn ihr das zu Hause nachmacht und
ich habe sie immer alle 4 cm einmal
durchgehackt und habe jetzt eigentlich
das perfekte Maß für so ein kipfall der
mit zwei has im Mund ist und jetzt
neimmt ihr euch einfach immer so ein
Teigling und dann im nach vorne und nach
hinten dann könnt ihr darauf achten dass
ihr dann während ihr das ganze ausrollt
in der Mitte das ganze dicker lässt als
außen also außen nicht zu dünnen sonst
verbrennt euch die Spitzen ist dann auch
blöd dann einfach nur so ein bisschen so
jetzt sieht das aus wie so eine
schupfnudel und die könnt ihr einfach so
nach innen biegen und dann ist auch
schon unser haselnus kipfall fast fertig
nach dem Backen wer ich natürlich noch
verzieren jetzt gebe ich das hier auf
mein Blech ich habe jetzt hier auch mein
Lochblech unten drunter das finde ich
bei Keksen immer perfekt Ofen habe ich
auch schon vorgehalzt auf 180° Ober und
Unterhitze und ich mache jetzt mal das
Blech voll lass immer ein bisschen
Abstand dazwischen und dann wird
gebacken so jetzt kommt der vanilleteig
das werden ja Vanille walnussplätzchen
und auch hier immer das gleiche
Spielchen ganz kurz geschmeidig kneten
und diesmal nicht zu einem Strang
ausrollen sondern
diesmal ja ich habe do gesagt du bist
jetzt du bist jetzt der Baum also
diesmal wird es einfach nur quasi
ausgerolltloren eigentlich ein Cut
gemacht B ich das in Ruhe hier
aus so lange alle ihr alle genauso wie
Baum stehen ach so okayen okay ich bin
jetzt auch schon soweit weil so lange
muss man das ja nicht kneten hauptsache
es ist wieder ein bisschen geschmeidig
dann Dream Team einmal die Silikonmatte
damit nichts anklebt und einmal hier der
ausrollstab ich habe jetzt hier 6 mm
Abstandsringe mit drin echt traurig weil
ich do
me Dream Team okay ich war schon so
bereit so und Silikonmatte wir sind auch
ein Dream Team ich bin die Silikonmatte
und du bist der Teigschaber so und jetzt
wird das schön ausgebreitet 6 mm und
diesmal stechen wir Kreise aus da könnt
ihr einfach irgendein
wenn ihr kein auscher da habt geht auch
keine Ahnung so ein kleines Pinnchen
eine kleine Schüssel oder das was wenn
du schon so toll W machst dann dreh das
bitte wenigstens einmal um so dam das
Logo sehen und so weißt du ja ich
verlinke euch sowieso immer alles in die
Infobox richtig cool 1890 199 wei ich
genau die hier kommt sogar Versand wenn
schon mal dabei sind die kommt sogar
Versandkosten
[Musik]
halbherzige ich steche mir jetzt Kreise
mit meiner großen Tülle aus und jetzt
habe ich noch mal ein Tipp für euch wenn
ihr das ganze ausstecht dann kann es
sein dass das hier drin stecken bleibt
und ihr das nicht rausbekommt so wie bei
mir gerade dann nehmt ihr euch einfach
ein bisschen Mehl geht da so rein dann
wieder gut abklopfen und dann ausstechen
weil dann guck mal es ist echt genial
dann bleibt da auch nichts mehr
[Musik]
kleben
jetzt kommen die nouattkekse dafür habe
ich hier meinen kakaoteig der wird jetzt
auch noch mal so ein bisschen geknetet
also wirklich nur so ein paar Sekunden
und dann damit ich es einfach besser
einteilen kann das ist wirklich am
einfachsten wenn ihr euch da wieder
einen Strang rollt und dann auch wieder
mit der teilarte
[Musik]
einteilt der Strang war jetzt wieder 2
cm dick und ich habe diesmal auch 2 cm
breite Streifen abgeschnitten und dann
einfach zu kugelnform aufs Backblech
legen und dann nimmt euch irgendein
Utensil das kann auch die Rückseite von
einem Kochlöffel sein ich habe jetzt
hier mein Honiglöffel und dann drücken
wir da einfach so eine Mulde rein nicht
ganz bis zum Boden natürlich und so wird
das jetzt auch gebacken im vorgeheizten
Backofen die Backzeiten blenden wir euch
immer ein schreibe ich euch aber
zusätzlich auch genauso wie alle ganz
genau Mengenangaben hier unten in die
Infobox und nach dem Backen wird das
richtig schön gefüllt also bis
gleich so hierzu habe ich noch mal ein
extra Tipp für euch wenn die Kekse ganz
heiß aus dem Ofen kommen neimmt ihr euch
noch mal einmal euer Tool was ihr
benutzt habt und dann drückt ihr in der
Mitte das Lochs noch mal so ein bisschen
ein weil das geht beim Backen natürlich
hoch aber wir wollen ja schön gleich mit
nussnouartceme befüllen die
kakaoplätzchen werden ja jetzt noch
getoppt mit nussnugartceme natürlich
nehme ich da meine eigene die ist ultra
lecker wir haben ja vor ein paar Wochen
schon gelauncht und ich habe schon so
viel positives Feedback von euch
bekommen was mich sehr sehr freut
natürlich ist die Creme komplett ohne
Palmöl und hat doppelt geröstete
Haselnusskerne mit drin aber sie
schmeckt jetzt auch anders das zeige ich
euch mal es gibt ja auch die Schokocreme
das ist wirklich nur eine Schoko bzw
Kakao Haselnusscreme das schmeckt dir
den haselnussanteil sehr raus weil da
sind auch mehr als doppelt so viele
Haselnusskerne mit drin und hier sind es
halt 15% was auch nicht wenig ist aber
hier schmeckt ihr halt mehr diesen ganz
typischen nougartgeschmack raus
natürlich könnt ihr die Creme nehmen die
ihr am liebsten möchtet es funktioniert
auch mit anderen Cremes aber es ist halt
super lecker und ich verlinke sie euch
auch gerne unten in die Infobox und
ansonsten ist das auch ein sehr sehr
leichtes Spielchen hier mit diesen
Keksen denn ich gebe sie einfach hier in
einen Spritzbeutel alternativ nehmt ihr
einfach ein Gefrierbeutel und dann
schneide ich vorne die Spitze ab und
dann werden einfach nur noch die Höhlen
[Musik]
befüllt für die haselnuskipfer wird
jetzt einmal Kuvertüre feing gehagt und
geschmolzen und ihr seht daran dass sie
fertig sind wenn sie außen also hier
wirklich noch hell sind und nur an der
Spitze ganz leicht goldbraun sind also
wartet jetzt nicht darauf dass der ganze
kipfall irgendwie goldbraun ist weil
dann ist er total trocken und so ist er
eben richtig zart und ich mach's jetzt
so dass ich die Kuvertüre einfach hier
in meinem Schmelztopf über einem
Wasserbad schmelze ich temperiere die
jetzt auch nicht temperieren wird jetzt
bedeuten zwei Drittel reingeben
schmelzen lassen letztes Drittel dazu
geben und bei Rest zu schmelzen lassen
das brauchen wir nicht in dem Fall kommt
er gleich eh noch mal Krokant oben
drüber daher könnt ihr das einfach schön
langsam hier im Schmelztopf eben dann
auf dem Wasserbad schmelzen lassen es
hat sich irgendwie so kompliziert an
aber meine ich nicht
[Musik]
so
die Spitzen der kipfall jetzt einfach in
die Kuvertüre tunken und zurück aufs
Backpapier geben ist ja sowieso alles
abgekühlt und jetzt dekorieren wir nur
noch mit
Haselnusskrokant schmeckt richtig lecker
und dann sind sie auch schon fertig da
muss die Schokolade natürlich noch
einziehen und dann machen wir uns an die
nächsten Plätzchen für die Vanille
walnussplätschen habe ich hier schon
weiße Kuvertüre fein gehackt ihr könnt
jetzt natürlich auch feollm oder
Zartbitter nehmen wenn ihr weiß nicht so
mögt ich persönlich finde das harmoniert
perfekt auch mit der walnus die doch so
ein ganz leicht bitteren Geschmack hat
und es ist so krass wenn ihr mal riecht
und die Plätzchen hier aus dem Ofen
kommen es riecht so stark nach Vanille
und jetzt mache ich so dass ich diesmal
aber temperiere das heißt ich gebe zwei
Drittel das könnt ihr nach Augenmaß
machen einfach in meinen Schmelztopf
hier habe ich wieder Wasser was ich
gerade erhitze wird dann richtig schönen
Glanz haben wenn ihr es nicht macht dann
hat die Schokolade halt so ein
Grauschleier und das sieht dann eben
nicht so schön aus das sind ungefähr
zwei Drittel dann lass ich das über
Wasserbad schmelzen nehm es dann runter
sobald es geschmolzen ist und gebt das
restliche Drittel mit dazu und dann
werden die Plätzchen einfach nur noch
überzogen und mit einer Walnuss
[Musik]
getoppt
so und fertig sind unsere Plätzchen es
sind natürlich noch viel mehr als das es
ist nur so viel wie hier auf mein
abkühlgitter gepasst hat auf jeden Fall
bin ich wieder sehr begeistert von
diesem Rezept und ich würde mal sagen
wer den Tast Test jetzt noch sehen
möchte der bleibt jetzt dran denn wir
fahren jetzt einmal in den Store und
lassen diesmal mal andere
[Musik]
probieren nur ein kann sein dass die NCE
da drin ist ist richtig gut richtig
lecker hast gebacken ja Sch sehr gut ich
mag sie boah richtig lecker ehrlich boah
das ist sogar noch besser schön das mit
ein aus richtig gut so reicht jetzt hier
also
[Musik]
ciao